what do you think should be
the covet policies for higher ed yeah so
I'm completely opposed to the vaccine
mandates
um I I sacrificed my career in academic
medicine to challenge the University of
California's vaccine mandate policy
these vaccines we knew from the very
beginning did not stop infection or
transmission of the virus therefore
whatever risks or benefits of the
vaccines there are accrued to the
individual who's accepting or declining
vaccination so that the whole argument
of get vaccinated for the sake of others
even if you're not worried even if
you're not going to benefit even if you
know you're at an age bracket that's you
know not high risk for problems with
covid that argument falls apart it
doesn't apply to these vaccines and so
we have to apply the traditional medical
ethics doctrine of informed consent
right where there's risk and we can
argue about how how risky these vaccines
are but where there's any degree of risk
there must be Choice there must be the
ability to voluntarily accept those
risks for the sake of potential benefits
or to decline them so on a purely
ethical uh grounds setting aside issues
of safety and efficacy of these vaccines
vaccine mandates are unethical
um and the I mean why are you paying
tuition at a school
uh with a policy like this where again
when you're healthy
you have to isolate right now look if
you have symptomatic illness of any kind
if you have any respiratory virus and it
you know you're really sort of
symptomatic in your coughing and
sneezing you got a fever yeah stay home
right
um
and uh maybe the campus could find a way
to you know if you have roommates or
another situation that makes it more
difficult to isolate maybe they could
facilitate a way to to give you a single
room for the people who are sick or
something like that fine fine but again
let's indiscriminately test people and
that anyone who comes back with a
positive test kicked them off campus I
mean this is just insane this is totally
insane why would you pay money to go to
an institution like this I just you know
I just can't it's it's it amazes me that
people subject themselves to this kind
of treatment uh and and Fork over tons
of money for the privilege of of being
treated like that it's it's yeah crazy
you were you were an early dissenter
from the tyrannical covid regime uh I
mean you were fired from UC Irvine
because of your refusal to comply with
the vaccine mandate could you tell us
your personal story how you made that
decision I mean you stuck by your
principles at tremendous personal cost
yeah
so I was the director of the medical
Ethics program which means that I did
all the ethics consults in the hospital
directed the ethics consult service I
taught the required ethics course to
medical students
and I was actually on a committee at the
UC Office of the President which oversaw
not just my Branch campus UC Irvine but
all the UCS UCLA UCSF we had a committee
with representation from all five of the
UC hospitals
bioethicists and critical care doctors
and we vetted basically all of the and
and wrote many of the covet policies
up until the vaccine mandate policy
which
puzzled me because it was clear to me
this was going to be the most ethically
controversial of any of the policies
that we had developed and so why hadn't
it gone through our committee it just
came down from the top came down from on
high and there was no discussion or
debate about it I tried to get a
conversation going at the Office of the
President about this policy because I
knew it was going to be publicly
controversial and I have serious
concerns about it
and was just met with radio silence so I
ended up
um in I think it was June of 21 uh
publishing an article in the Wall Street
Journal with the title University
vaccine mandates are unethical and as I
mentioned before those were the first
institutions mandating vaccines that's
why I sort of focused on universities
and I made the case that I just made to
you regarding inform informed consent
and then I passed that around to the
committee to try to stir the pot and you
know get get some discussion and again
no discussion no debate we're not
talking about this and a week or two
later the proposed policy was finalized
and then once the policy went in so if
nobody engaged with it nobody engaged
with that Wall Street Journal article
not at all not at all yeah which I found
because these were people that we
I was on the phone with the UC general
counsel like every night hammering out
all these other covert policies with
ventilator triage policy the vaccine
allocation policy who should get it
first when it first rolls out
um all that kind of stuff and then
suddenly nope this is uh this is not
under discussion it was just very
bizarre
and then once they instituted it I
started seeing my colleagues getting
steamrolled so I because I had written
the piece in the in the journal I was
publicly known as an opponent of the
policy I had students and faculty and
staff reaching out to me students saying
things like I'm not a religious person
so I can't in good conscience submit a
religious exemption to their credit
they're trying to be you know ethically
scrupulous
um but I have conscience-based
objections to this vaccines or I have
medical concerns about safety and
efficacy and it became virtually
impossible to get a medical exemption
even in circumstances where that might
have been appropriate in California
because the California medical board was
threatening Physicians who wrote any
exemptions basically
um so it was a really terrible situation
I was seeing students getting kicked out
I was seeing nurses that worked every
day during the pandemic and had worked
at the University Hospital
you know alongside me for 15 years uh
getting fired
and I just got to the point where it was
like okay I can be an ivory Tower
intellectual and you know I've said my
piece I've made my case it actually
hasn't had an effect or
um I can actually try to do something to
change this policy
and uh I think that the the the final
decision came down to just trying to
project ahead a few months to where I
would start teaching the
um annual ethics course to the med
students and just feeling like I
couldn't stand up with any credibility
and talk about informed consent talk
about moral courage and integrity if I
hadn't tried to do something so I made
the Fatal decision to challenge that
mandate in federal court
um and the university immediately moved
to to get rid of me
um on the pretense of alleged
non-compliance with the same policy that
I was uh challenging in federal court I
say alleged because the university also
twice denied my medical exemption that
was signed by my physician so that's
what happened to me
um did you have the opportunity to
appeal that denial of medical exemption
uh I did and they denied it again on wow
so
thanks for watching that clip from our
conversation with Aaron carriati about
the return of kovid mandates and his
book the new abnormal you can watch
another clip from that conversation
right here or the full conversation over
here